I don't think I want to make a serious
running to try and take first place but
we'll see RT shock my favorite opening
is a London opening and I'm here for a
chess nice to hear your comments you're
welcome
so this is my first game where I'm black
let's play a black opening can I make
shorter YouTube videos yeah well I guess
it depends what sort of content I'm
making a lot of the YouTube content is
just archives of streams and it can take
a little bit of effort to edit down the
streams but hopefully at least with this
stream I'll separate the the games into
each individual videos let's play Queens
gambit declined there's actually a
comment on youtube I think my most
recent video the very first comment had
nothing to do with the video
it just said can you please make a video
about qgd so maybe that will be this
video we have a huge IDI which is one of
my favorite openings actually to play
against d4 it's one of the few openings
I've been playing like my whole life
since I first learned chess like the
first opening my coach taught me and
over the years I've learned kind of the
ins and outs and the nuances and found
ways to make it dynamic and try and play
for a win I forgot to play the Budapest
I'm sorry to people who wanted to
Budapest mainly the fucsia and patrick
jmt what do I think is the best response
to d4 for amateurs Queens got declined I
think is a good starting points Budapest
is also very effective at amateur level
because there's so many traps
I did make a study on me just how to
play against 1d for where I give some
recommendations you're just gonna play
what I normally play in tournaments just
written seven play solidly I was
considering for a moment to play semi
Slav but I'm just gonna stick it my
comfort zone have I ever played with dr.
reichter's Dean I have not but I played
with man with a van I've heard is a
similar person that's castle still
theory passed upon 99 and the chat it's
going well I'm already tired been
streaming for just over an hour
classical chess it's so tiring III okay
I'm gonna play a so called pet line a
sixes not the main move like more common
is usually h6 and then black eventually
players like b6 or 94 but a6 is a move
I've studied a decent amount the idea is
like on the surface idea is to take on
c4 play b5 this should be seven and c5
and depending what white does there's
different different ways of handling the
position the main moves for whites
Bishop e2 I don't think is a great move
actually because it's just wasting time
because now the bishop basically has to
move again to take the pawn and then it
has to move again after b5 so I get a
lot of kind of free Tempe
and we're gonna get some relatively
dynamic position I'll have a very nice
Bishop on b7 and then very soon I'll go
for c5 usually the plan is Bishop e7
Knight B to d7 c5 Queen b6 rook c8 and
rook FD eights and hopefully that
terrifies my opponent so let's play this
first
go play night bt7 first because after he
see five if he takes I want to take back
with the Knights another sub lemmiwinks
thanks for the Salomon tier 2 sub that's
not too common do you appreciate that
there are there's three tiers of subs if
you're a tier 2 sub you got access to my
face I think I think that's a tier 2
emote not too many people have access to
that emote okay so you also play b4 if
he got an extra move and played before
it's actually a very strong positional
bind for whites but thankfully I can
play c5 and be happy
if takes on c5 Knight takes e5 hey
there's the emotes okay
and now I don't want to trade Queens the
thing about this position is it's just
so pleasant the rooks come in I was
about to say that white doesn't have a
great place for the Queen but I'll
probably play Queen e2 and then wring
his rook soon so it's still going to be
a fight
I'll start with rook c8
have to be a little bit careful like
before at some points my night gets
awkward
I'll start with rook see it's can't be
that bad
if before I probably have to move back
to t7 past pond 99 with more emotes yeah
I made some Newton emotes recently I
made a steak steak steak emote for what
happens when I say take steak steak it
takes takes takes too many times starts
sounding like steak steak steak so the
subscribers to Nakamura we'll use our
takes takes takes and then my
subscribers will use steak steak steak
it's hard to say that too many times in
a row I also made the toilet noggin
emotes which was long overdue I was at
Starbucks the other day I was on my
laptop designing the emotes I felt like
the people around me were judging me
like I was photoshopping the brain into
the toilets okay rook Siwon is played I
was expecting maybe Rick fd1 but that's
a playable move maybe it's time for
rookie eight so I've accomplished like
my whole arrow setup which I had earlier
which I said my opponent might be
terrified about but it's actually
somewhat symmetrical like it's gonna
take work to win this because we might
be trading rooks I'm realizing my knight
probably wants to go back to d7
in 97 and I'm envisioning night I fade
to g6 where it's a more happy peace
and I'm essentially putting the question
to my opponent like what is he gonna do
next because at least I have some plan
of improving I'm curious what white will
do to try and strengthen the position
maybe he'll self-destruct which would be
nice
what does that steak emote mean I feel
like I try I just try to answer that
maybe I didn't answer it well enough
okay so he plays Bishop b1 maybe he
wants to play Queen c2 and make me so
this is one reason to put the knight on
g6 simply defending the king's side why
no Budapest this game because it's
classical chess I want something a bit
more classical maybe if I got a chance
I'll played with a pest in the future
makes me feel bad people are crying
let's play Knight g6 you hurt your knee
really badly you had to be carried home
what were you doing I hope you weren't
playing chess I mean the great thing
about chess is you can injure like
everything or break every not break
every phone but you can be in not great
physical condition and still be capable
of playing chess but yeah I cook kiyomi
I hope you're not like too physically
damaged and on the other hand that
sounds fun to be carried home I do have
a discord impeccable King moobot should
deliver Collymore if asking any tips for
shark gambits
for whites that's hard to defend even in
slow chess I mean it's a pencil black
place because when you play e4 there's
many different types of Defense's so
within each defense there's gambits I
mean Ivan's gambit is probably one of
the most feminists against e4 e5 Fabiano
was losing a game a couple years ago to
roofing Lee the millionaire chess
tournaments
so Evans gambit against b-45
I mean Smith Morra is certainly playable
if you're prepared against Sicilian you
have to be well-prepared though if you
want to be well-prepared ghetto sermons
book mayhem in the moral French defense
I can't think of too many gambits
against French there's a wing gambit
that's playable do I take I probably
don't want to take it's taking it makes
it more difficult to wind so let's see
it there's a slim possibility I have
some tactical threats of taking on a 3
because this pawn is currently
overworked
you know Belgrade gambits other lawyer
openings are there against efore yeah
against the Celia Nancy 45 against
Scandinavian there's this funny gambit
you take on d5 Queen takes d5 Knight c3
coin a5 and then you play d4 I did a
video on that on YouTube what am I like
very early chess videos and gets called
how to crush the Scandinavian okay Queen
d2 what is going on d8 we can repeat I
could take on that three giving away my
beautiful bishop to double white spawns
could play before I could play h6
doesn't feel right
I feel like I shouldn't be calculating
and concretely there's a variation takes
takes 95 hitting f3 with a massive fork
and so queen g2 Kim G 2 or Queen e2
would be expected and then I play Queen
East or queen c6 hitting the pawn again
and you play the other King G 2 or Queen
e2 and then I take on 83
looks playable I have night c4 ideas -
let's do it sometimes to beat weaker
players or just to beat any player you
have to create some imbalances makes the
position more sharp maybe take some risk
but hopefully it's worth it and the I
mean this could maybe be considered a
tactic that Queen c6 is essentially a
double threats and threatening obviously
to take on a three and I have threats of
taking on a three because of the battery
so we'll see what happens
trying to calculate Bishop efore Pawnee
for Pawnee for Ismaili move I considered
looks that looks like very bad
positionally that maybe it's playable it
does defend f3 Knight C for is like the
first move that comes to mind because
then it opens up more possibilities with
tactics against these pawns and it hits
a queen I think I'll just play this
without thinking too much
that's why not usually I'll play are all
considered at least a few options but I
mean this just looks so nice hitting the
Queen and now if black or if white moves
like Queen c2 then I take on a3 and then
keeping initiative winning a pawn maybe
even winning two pawns because if he
takes I take on a threes weak
doing mean do we need mods in the chats
or no I don't think mods commute other
mods unless they can okay Queenie - now
there's a really interesting move here
Knight h5 i have tactics with taking
either pawn Knight h5 just looks so much
fun because if bishop takes you seven i
fork the king and queen so bishop could
retreat
[Music]
I mean maybe I should just take on b2
looks very simple but then II v e5 then
maybe 9 h5 I take on B - Queen takes b2
also e5 I just take on d1 so it takes
takes takes takes takes e5 way that
could be troublesome takes takes takes
takes takes e5 that could be very
troublesome because my t5 he takes takes
and then meets me and yet so maybe I
can't take on me too
so maybe I just play h6
yeah let's play h6 there's still like
back rank issues but
at least I'm making him think
so Knight takes Knight takes me to ni
takes a three we're probably just
blenders or no Knight takes a three
would have been a knight takes a three
probably wasn't good either because
after Queen takes c3 there's rook c1
with a skewer and the bishop defends you
want
chess is complicated cascades with a sub
thanks cash judge whatever your name is
five months in a row well I like the
position white has a few options but all
of them seem to be nice for black I mean
this line looks very nice so the tension
remains so now the question is can I
take on b2 here I could take on a three
here now the bishop is not controlling
c1 but I want to take on b2 takes okay
we trade everything in the e5 problem is
'if I've controls h7 and there's still
back rank mate issues
so maybe I played g5 oh wait no I can
play this move now because the square is
undefended the bishops undefended has to
play Bishop g3i trade and then I win b2
that looks pretty smooth
actually the bathing whether it's in the
pawner go for something like Bishop c5
at some points I think I should take
first I mean take and then take on b2
and then it just seems very clean the
great thing about taking on b2 is that
I'm attacking the rook and the Knights
and the pause so more things are loose
and even though there will be some oxic
Lord Bishop position I'll be up material
of you I think I'm just winning this
pawn so I'll be up to pawns Belgium
novice is back welcome back just in time
for the endgame
yeah this is nice
as if 'if I've okay he just for science
that's nice yeah it was I mean it seemed
equal kind of out of the opening but I
think that the key transformation was
Bishop takes f3 and then actually every
move starting with Bishop takes off 3
was initiative basically until the rest
of the game like I capture I attack I
keep attacking keep attacking and then
wind stuff never underestimate
initiative